シャシャシャシャッ
バァンッ‼︎
ガチャッ
おい、帰ったぞ...
あ、うっす。お疲れさまです。兄貴
バンバンバババンッ
卍今日も３人ぐらい殺っちまったよ...卍
ぅあ...
さすがっス、兄貴...
卍Splatoon卍でな
卍おめぇらぁ...卍
卍タバコ吸ってか？卍
卍お前、吸ってか？卍
吸ってないっス...
卍いい心がけだ卍
卍おめぇら...卍
卍タバコは身体に良くねぇ卍
卍極力、やめといた方がいい...卍
卍そして、未成年は吸うな卍
卍そんなオレもタバコを吸っちゃいねぇが...卍
卍これ...知ってっか？卍
卍これ！卍
卍電子タバコってんだ卍
卍今、巷で話題になってる！卍
卍オレも昔、１回動画にしたこと ある’’る’’る’’が！卍
卍電子タバコなんだが...卍
ニコチン ０！卍
タール...０！卍
本製品はタバコではあり’’り’’ません卍
卍つまりお前、これ何が言いたいかっていうと...卍
卍こりゃ、タバコじゃねぇんだ卍
卍タバコっぽい形をした、タバコじゃねぇヤツだよ...卍
卍だがらぁ...卍
卍身体に害は無ぇ卍
卍けど！卍
卍タバコっぽい...
あの...独特な感じが味わえる卍
卍すげぇ代モンだ！卍
卍とりあえずこれ、１回吸ってみよう卍
卍これが...オトナの嗜みだ！卍
うっす。
（ヒュゥ〜）
卍どうだ...？卍
ｶｯｹｪｽｱﾆｷwww
HAHA！そぉだろ！！
卍そうだ。お前らタバコってのは...卍
卍かっけんだ...卍
卍でも！卍
卍身体に良くねぇ...卍
卍そして、周りの人に迷惑を掛けてしまう...卍
卍そ～ゆ～ヒトの為にこの！卍
卍害の無い電子タバコってヤツがあるんだ卍
卍覚えとけぇ！！卍
ウォオゥスゥッ！（？）
トゥントゥントゥントゥン…略
かっけぇっスｗｗ
卍だろｗｗ卍
卍というわけで卍
卍これは今、無味無臭の電子タバコだったが...卍
卍電子ば、いたぅわ...
さぁせんしたｗ
卍俺は今日、どこ行ったか分かるか？卍
卍ドンキだ！卍
！？
兄貴、ドンキなんか行ってきたんすか！？
卍行っちまったよぉお！！ 卍
卍見ろぉお！！卍
ｗｗｗｗ
花粉の...花粉の薬が...ｗ
卍オレ 今、ドンキに行ってきて！卍
卍ドンキに売ってた電子タバコ
全部買ってやったぞ！卍
卍電子タバコっつーのは卍
卍今や色んな種類の味があって卍
卍それぞれ、色んなフレーバーを楽しめる卍
卍こんだけ色んな味の電子タバコが売ってた卍
卍これは全部！卍
ｶﾗﾀﾞﾆｶﾞｲﾊﾈｪwwww
色んな味がある...
卍Grapefruit Mint！
Muscat Menthol！
Energy Drink！
Blueberry！
Apple！
Vanilla！
Menthol Mint！
Charming Cherry！
Vintage Vanilla！
Boisterous Berry！
Cool Citrus！
Marvelous Mint！
ｻ...ｸﾞｯ...
strawberry！卍
卍というわけで今日は卍
卍お前らただ普通に電子タバコ吸ってんじゃねぇぞぉ卍
卍１本だけ吸ってちゃ
楽しくねぇぇええ！！！卍
卍というわけで今日は卍
卍電子タバコは色んな味があるんだが卍
卍それぞれ、おいしいわけよ卍
卍電子タバコ、どれもとてもおいしい味がするんだが...卍
卍１個１個吸ってても
埒が明かねぇぇええ！！！卍
というわけで今日は
電子タバコをこれ色々あるんスけど
全部、まとめて一束にして！
俺が全部...
卍吸ってやんよぉぉおお！！！卍
卍どんな味になるか、すげぇ気になるよなぁ卍
ｷﾆﾅﾙｩｯｽww
ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
まってｗヤバいｗｗｗｗｗ
（♪〜）
まって、これやべぇなぁ...
卍このままやっちまうとよぉ...卍
うん...
モノすげぇ量の煙が俺の身体の中に蔓延して...
卍もってかれるぞぉぉおお！！！卍
卍とゆわけで、全部のタバコが出終わりました卍
卍すげぇ量の電子タバコだなぁ...卍
卍POSCAより多いかもなぁ！卍
卍というわけで、オレは今から
これをまとめて一束にして卍
卍吸う！卍
卍それがどんなことを意味してるか分かるよな...卍
卍１４本の電子タバコが１つになる...卍
卍つまり！卍
卍普通に電子タバコを吸引する奴の１４倍！
俺はいっきに煙が体内に入り込んじゃうｗｗ
卍ま、オレが一番知りてぇのは卍
卍実際、どんな感じになるのか卍
卍そして、味だ卍
卍ホント、フルーティーな味が多かったんで卍
卍すげぇ気になるとこではあるな！卍
まってこれｗｗｗｗｗ
ｗｗｗｗｗ
卍じゃあさっそく、吸ってみるぅ！卍
卍いくぞ～卍
うっす。
俺、死なないよねぇ...
死にます！
卍もう、わぁたやるかんなオレ卍
卍お前ホント知らないかんなおまホントに...
さぁせんでした...
橋本環奈、お前ぇ...
卍はい、行きまぁす！卍
３...２...１...
アハァ〜ン
ゲッフオッホ
卍もう一回行くぞぉ？卍
（フンフン）
ウォエェベェェウォェエッホンッ！
すげぇよ...
ｹﾑﾘﾃﾞﾐﾀｻﾚﾀﾊ!?
（さっきと同じ）
卍魅せてやれぇ卍
卍男の意地ってもんを！卍
シャシャシャシャッ
バァンッ‼︎
ガチャッ
バンバンバババンッ